hey y'all attention couch here and this
tell you Tuesday video I'm actually not
gonna work on this week's data set
instead I'm actually enough folks on
feature engineering with the recipes
package so when I was looking at the
recipes package I actually saw that they
had like an ordering of steps article
which kind of shows you a little
checklist of how to actually use the
recipes package in a specific workflow
so I thought it'd be fun to kind of do
this go through this checklist and use
the famous Titanic data set and for the
Titanic data set um each row basically
represents a passenger on the Titanic
and whether they survived it or not
so it's a great predictive modeling
problem and you can learn a lot in fact
the first time I was actually using are
the Titanic data set it was the first
day so I was actually analyzing and I
was actually doing that in besar so that
was a lot of fun so we're actually gonna
load up our markdown file let's see it
from template document i'll call this
the tidy tuesday titanic okay cool so
we're gonna load in the tidy verse the
tidy models package and our data set so
DF read CSV Titanic CSV okay so first
let's just do a basic summary of it and
we can see that we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
columns we can see our survived column
which what we're trying to predict and
it appears to be a binary variable of
zeros and ones one i'm gonna assume is
that they survived and 0 if they did not
addition we have 7 other columns we have
i guess p class name sex age cool so
when actually looking at some data sets
for predictive modeling it's pretty
important to look at the data quality
issues so the biggest thing is just
seeing how many na s are missing values
there are and this summary function kind
of shows each column or each features
toll na s
that's pretty helpful because if you are
looking at your data
and you notice say um one feature is
missing half its values it's worth
considering actually dropping the tire
feature additionally one way one other
thing we she'll get is I guess row wise
total na s so if a sample is missing say
half of its features is worth
considering also dropping that sample
and not using that in your data in your
modeling or analysis additionally if you
see that say a lot of na s are centered
around a certain feature say for example
highly pay high fares have more na s
than low fares it might be worth
considering why that's happening for me
I actually know that these n A's are
random because I went into the data set
and ran we removed some values but we're
actually gonna find out say the the row
wise total count of n A's
okay so I actually don't really know
what an elegant solution to finding out
unlike the row wise counts I know
there's a row wise function well I'm not
sure what that does so maybe if I look
at that row wise row wise do so there's
something going something it's paired
with a do so it's some type of like I
guess like mapping style thing but I
know one way I would I know one way I
would do is basically so I would
probably just make a essentially a row
key in this case we could use name but
sometimes we might not have a unique
classifier so that's all we're gonna do
we're gonna say mutate and we'll say row
K equals a row number right and then
what I would do is I would do like
gather so key equals key value equals
value and then minus row key okay so now
we have that and then finally I would
say filter value that value is our na
and then I would just count the row key
and then maybe say I got a sword equals
true
right so right here we're just counting
the missing values in each row and we
can see that okay the most amount of
missing features is - I'm comfortable
with that
even though there's only about one two
three four five six so one-third of the
total features are missing at max and
that's only with two of those samples
I'm fine with that I would say that it's
definitely dependent on on the person
the amount of features you don't have
right so we're gonna just deal with that
and let's look at the actual recipes
steps so the first thing I should do is
do any imputation zhh okay so we're
gonna do that okay first time say two
row wise counts of n A's and A's okay so
we're gonna do a summary again and let's
first focus on um P class okay so if we
will get P class let's just do some
summary statistics of it so we can do
that we can do a let's here group by P
class and let's say summarize count
equals n average age equals mean age and
say I guess na done RM equals true
average fare equals mean fare and age
are M equals okay so what we can see
here okay so we're missing for um p
classes and this this in this case I
think it's payment class because we see
here with the average fare that the
first class people are paying a much
higher fare terror class people are
paying less fair middle class or second
class a pan you know a little bit over
the lower third class fare and usually
what we can see is kind of the basic
counts of each class so we can see that
Oh the majority of people were in the
third class then in first class and then
in second class okay so there's kind of
a dispersion right there we don't see
that aid you kind of Center on 25 or
three
there's not a huge age difference
between the third and second class
however the first class people are a
little bit older we can also look at our
na s and see that okay for our average
NA age it's actually was 39 so they're
much older
however they have a much lower fare so
that could mean a few things I want it
could mean that there's a person in this
sample it has a much higher acre as much
older and it also could mean that one
person has a much lower fare so let's
look at that so let's say filter P class
is n/a okay and we look let's look at
that we can see the fair is centered
around what I would say is that the
second I guess it's a center around a
little bit but all of them so this
person misterfrancis davis is probably
maybe a upper second-class person but
the majorities people are probably in
the first in the third class right idea
so we can see how this guy is much older
and also that he's paying more so if
you're older and paying more I would say
you probably fit in the first class
however these young people who are
paying way less I guess this young
person who's paying less and these
people are paying much less I would have
a center around senator tell them that
there are they are probably in the third
class so these type of like kind of like
not necessarily not necessarily hard
combinations but it's something where
you kind of are comparing the
similarities and it appears to be
meeting some type of pattern we can
impute this using the KNN imputation
algorithm and they actually have this
thing called step can and impute well we
could do a mean meeting or mode but
since we see that there's other things
that are kind of how are these small
indicators that we think are intuitive
we can actually use a kind of machine
learning algorithm to actually the
imputations which should be a little bit
more robust estimate but if you want to
be safe you can do a median so that's
all we're gonna we're gonna do the step
can impute okay so we're and say step K
and N and pew and I'm actually going to
do
some data cleaning first so first we
should do but first we need to clean so
if we will get our data set one thing we
don't need is we don't need the name
okay the name can basically act as a
primary key so we don't want that okay
additionally what we should do is we
should mutate sex
it's equal to as that factor sex and
also survive is equal to as that factor
as that factor survived okay so we have
that we have P class which int I think a
payment class can definitely be senator
served as a factor so it was AP class
goes as a factor P class okay so we have
what three factors and the rest of these
guys I would say are these like
continuous variables so we don't worry
about that okay so we got that now it's
a definer recipe it's a recipe and in
this case what we're trying to do is
we're trying to predict survived so as
they survive data equals DF for this
example we're actually not gonna do any
modeling right now we're actually gonna
focus most on the feature engineering so
we're doing basically is you using the
entire data set which will cause leakage
if you want to use this in the modeling
however it is very simple we could just
do a training and testing split and then
just use a training data but since we
want to see kind of this like tactile
feedback we're just gonna apply it to
the entire data set to get some type of
intuition I also figure out what it's
doing
okay so we'll say what's this called
Titanic I'm Titanic wreck boom Oh
Titanic wreck we can look at that what's
good okay so a Titanic wreck we can do
the imputation so step was it cannon and
pew and we want to impute this to the PE
class right so suing that it's applying
the K nearest neighbor imputation for a
P class
cool okay so next what we get what we
need to do is simply finish P class well
we start looking at oh it's here well we
should start looking at is this the
number of sex the sex okay so in this
case if we do a count sex we can see
that there's five missing values the
majority the sex is male okay so that's
pretty interesting
um one thing that we should do is we
should just do a group by sex and maybe
do it just to summarize and say like
just to maybe do an average age equals
mean age average fair fair equals being
fair so we're gonna do that we can see
the oh and Ida are m and E are true and
then you are out it goes true okay cool
so we got that
what is our missing values showing us
well our missing values are appears to
be on average older and on average has
lost money that is a strong indication
of male so let's look at that say DF
filter sex is a name okay so we got that
they're definitely older they're paying
more money one percent is sibling first
and then two of them two of the five
survived cool so for me when I'm looking
at this I don't I'm not really certain
on how it's gonna work
additionally since this is a factor or
categorical variable we can't use median
or or mean so one way that we can do
this is we can do a modal imputation so
we're gonna impute the most common value
so that's what we're going to do so when
we say impute the modal Kat
gorac all value tight so say a Titanic
rack step mode and pute and we're going
to apply this to sex very cool
cool so we have that we can do another
summary just to see what else we need to
do okay so now we're gonna do sibling
and parent - oh we can do age okay let's
do it let's do H - okay so with age I'm
not even gonna look at the actual
crosstabs I'm gonna just do a simple
plot so let's do the plot age but genome
density so when I'm looking at this we
see that age is definitely centered
around this big hump right here which
begs the question should you kind of
like a mean or median so let's look at
that if we look at our ages we can see
the difference is which is between
basically one and a half years okay
since we're doing age I'm just gonna do
median I think when I think of age I
always think median value so that's
we're gonna do where it's a impute using
median age okay it's a Titanic wreck
step median impute age right yeah let's
do it
cool so we have that now what we're
gonna do is sibling and spouses so I'm
just gonna copy this and that's a lot of
text okay so we're gonna do DF select
these guys and one thing that I was
looking at is okay so parents and
children aboard let's just do some let's
see let's just do a basic plot so it's
to gather and maybe just do a GG plot so
GG plot yes x equals value color
oops color equals key plus genome
jiya mouth what could we do here
Jim histogram was facet wrap like a
scale as he goes free
okay so we're gonna do that cool so
what's a year most of the time it's
centered around zero however for
siblings spouses it also has a little
hump at one this little point at one and
just intuitive that kind of makes sense
because okay if you have a spouse on
board they're probably the spouses also
can be counted and they were gonna say
they have a spouse on board okay whereas
if you have a parent on board you might
just have only have like a mom on board
or a dad on board and you're probably
not gonna have you might not have more
than one children so that makes sense um
I guess like the parent and children
thing a child could be counted and they
could say they have a parent however it
appears that there's way less children
on maybe in general whereas there might
there's probably more likely to be
spouses when traveling on the Titanic
okay so what does that mean well we can
do a lot of things if we look at this we
can say okay on one hand we could do a
we can we'll get the summary statistics
and we see okay most time it's zero so
we could do a mean which a medium which
means zero what could do a mean in this
case I think the smartest way to do it
since um you will can't have half a
sibling have a parent on board I think
we should still do mode so we're gonna
do that we're going to say since you
cannot have a half a parent or sibling a
board let's compute with mode obviously
you could just do median and mean but
we're kind of just gonna do this as just
as simple as possible so we're gonna
impute using mode okay so Titanic wreck
step mode and pute and we're gonna say
siblings parents children aboard
- okay cool
so we have that and I'll ask you will do
fair okay DF will just do GG pot yes
Xcode fair but Jim and City okay and
then maybe I'll do a plus scale oops
X log 10 so log 10 so it's increments of
10
I like log logarithm 10 so when you see
there's three humps and that's kind of
interesting when when I'm looking this
I'm thinking oh I bet this represents
like the three classes all right so
let's do that
let's see what that goes fill equals P
class yeah and that's what we're kind of
getting maybe I'll do color equals P
cause yeah color equals P class so what
are we seeing here on one hand we can
see okay well our fair is definitely I'm
kind of senator around the third class
and we have all these other classes so
it could be it like a a third or second
class so let's look at the actual
densities without it again and we look
at that okay so let's a look at now
let's look at the summary statistics so
select fair and we'll do a summary let
me see a comedian mean for me since I
think it's in between first and second
class and we can see that our second
classes for a second third class um
fairs are kinda in between each other so
it's 1320
what's see here 30 or 20 actually I'm
gonna do a min fair some men men men
fair equal equals men fair and I doubt
our M equals true let's see what that
looks like so the min fair third class
13 25 2000 K 13 25 I'm gonna say system
in fair oh I don't say
filter air just not equal zero just of
justice get an idea what the min fair
was looking at for second class four
okay so hmm
third okay so I'm gonna do the the
median I feel very comfortable the
median so what's a MPU fair with the
median value on a strong suspicion that
it is third force or a second class
actually what third a third or second
class so if we do uh let's let's just do
another filter then filter bear is a
second class so the second class that
means what we can do is we can do the
actual mean okay actually instead
stretch also scratch that MP you using
means since the PE class is second class
okay so we're gonna impute using the
mean so Titanic wreck step mean impute
fair cool so we did that we finished
with that recipe so let's go back
ordering the steps we got done with
imputation we can do individual
transferring a transformations for
skewness so let's see if any of these
values are highly skewed that we feel
that might raise some complications okay
so if we look at our summary we can we
yeah there we go sorry
well you notice that our minimum value
does not go below zero so if you look at
this if using box-cox transformation
don't Center the data first or do any
operations that might make the data non
pasta alternatively use the huge
constant so you don't have to worry
about this so when I'm looking at this
we don't we can use center scale you
Jeong Gyo Johnson or box-cox
for me I sees box-cox because I kind of
like it um especially if we don't have
non non negative numbers so um we can
keep that in our heads this is for most
of our individual transformations so
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
say I still select what suck if is that
factor fact select Oh God
select suck that ball how does a not not
is that no bars
select was like at is dot bars is dot
back Oh God
okay no we're not gonna do it so select
select add he's not select if how do I
do the let's see here select if I
serious select it not tiny vers what's
the apron I think how did I do this
again oh well we're not gonna worry
about that so we're gonna do DF select -
survived - P class - sex maybe do that
throwing it gather and then just do a GD
plot a es x equals value
Phil Phil equals key [ __ ] um histogram
plus facet wrap my key scales equals
free
so how do I suck non-numeric select if
negate oh okay so I do select if negate
a gate is dot factor cool tells really
easy
okay cool so we can see that um age it
you know it's showing kind of like a
normal issue distribution we can see how
these guys are are not it's mostly
center around you know it they'll left I
don't know the exact name of that
distribution maybe it's a good
experiment like that
I don't know I'm one thing I was
thinking maybe we do like a scale or X
log ten and see if that does anything
and that doesn't change anything too
much so we're just at that okay so we
kind of look at it
no distributions are super concerning so
I'm going to kind of check this off and
say ok we can keep on going on to the
next list which is just discretize
discretize is it's actually binning so
say if we see fair we could say we can
essentially make the payment class so we
could say oh like fair between zero and
100 is a non upper-class hundred dollars
learn and above is upper class we don't
have one all I need to worry about that
right now so we're gonna go on to the
next one which is the create the dummy
variables okay so we know we have
factors so we're gonna say finished
imputing now let's put let's put in some
dummy VARs okay so if we do DF we know
we have three different factors however
we're trying predict survived so we only
have to convert P class and sex into
atomic variables so that's all we're
gonna do
let's see your Titanic track step dummy
dummy
and then let's do P class and sex in
this case I'm not gonna do any one high
in coding so I'm seduced this
dummy bar so we're gonna we'll get that
we have the dummy bar and we're gonna do
that so cool we got finished with the
dummy bar
let's what's next so we can create
interactions in this case I don't feel
comfortable making any interactions that
there could be an interaction between
say your sibling and fair I'm not sure
but that's something where you you you'd
have to do a bigger eda and I think I
don't want to make this video too long
so we're gonna go to the next step which
is these global normalization steps
okay so noir normalization so most
models actually benefit from some type
of standardization or normalization I
honestly don't know of a model that gets
actually hurt by normalization one thing
that I would maybe think about is maybe
normalization might hurt say like I got
like a stand model which really wants
these wants to preserve these specific
distributions but I don't have a deep
understanding of that so I would say a
good rule of thumb is always normalized
I certainly can't hurt you and if you
know when did not normalize then you're
probably out of the scope of this class
or out of this video so we're gonna
start normalization if we go to the
function function around for instance I
mean see there's actually a decent
amount let's here do you fit decent
amount of know my stations
so there's step center step normalized
which does the sarin scaling we do step
range step scale so we can kind of side
one hand we could do a box-cox
transformation which I actually enjoyed
doing we also do is say you know Johnson
but I think the the default thing that
you could do if if you don't really know
what to do or if you kind of don't wanna
look at anything I think a step
normalized is the best and this applies
both as turning and scaling so that's
what we can do
Titanic
wreck and step normalize and I would
believe was at all all and we just do is
all numeric I think all numeric is that
the go to one let me check that let's
see if my Internet's slow why is my
internet so low
okay I think it's all numeric let's see
what that does steps entering for all
numeric doesn't oh okay
so all numeric I'm gonna keep it let's
see let's see what happens let's see
what happens so step almost all numeric
we applied it I don't know why this
thing is huh weird so we did that we
finished step six and now we're on step
seven
where's the multivariate transformations
always I'm not very familiar with a lot
of these but I've seen say obviously
like PCA I think spatial sign
pre-processing so all of these things
you could definitely do a huge thing
into it um it definitely goes with say
like it's kind of like distances between
each calms and the on the relative
amount of samples and it's something
that could be done I guess I was like
kind of a feature reduction there's also
other things like say removing highly
correlated values which is definitely
necessary saying like linear regression
for like multicollinearity
there's also nzv or near zero variance
and zero variance which it basically
says that if a value doesn't change so
it's like a very if the value stays for
the entire dataset we'll just remove it
P is redundant and you can give it
wiggle room for the near zero variance
then there's also these row operations
like you can do filtering you can do lag
features you can do I guess shuffling
you do sampling like down sampling and
up sampling you can also do I guess I
don't intercept call them window
functions and stuff like that but we
don't need to do that
so we're gonna do final oops
finally prep and bake the recipe so
let's say Titanic prep prep Titanic
wreck data should be character or factor
to would compute the mode Oh what the
Titanic wreck let's hear my supposed to
change why is the saying what data
should be character or factor to compute
the mode let's here
step centers edited it out what's here
hmm
very odd let me look this up recipe okay
I'm gonna stop this video and see what's
going on so I write that I I was running
some errors with the was it with the the
siblings abroad and the parents abroad
with the modem computation it I guess I
guess it requires a character so we're
just gonna ignore that and just kind of
let it ride okay
so instead of using a modal impute we're
just gonna do the the median impute so
we're gonna just do siblings dots
spouses dot board and parents taught
children troops two children got a board
okay and we're gonna prep put that into
a prep so we're gonna throw in the prep
oops so instead I'm just gonna do a I'm
gonna show the entire thing so Titanic
prep okay and then finally what we're
gonna do is we're gonna bake it or apply
the alcohol pre-processing function to
the data set
cuz we're gonna bake it and say Titanic
prep with the df' what do we see here so
first we can see the age is centered
scaled siblings parents fair survived
sweet okay so I think that's what we
need - 1 2 3 4 5 and then 6 and then
that's our 7 we also can do a summary
statistic
see if we are missing anything we are
not missing so survive is still missing
one and that is something where we can
actually drop the NA for that so that's
what we're gonna do we're say processed
D F fake and then we'll do process D F
and we'll say I dropped any of the
remaining n A's and boom okay so then we
have a process D F and we can finally
use it for actual modeling and stuff
like that with Italian models you
actually won't see it but you'll it'll
kind of this is kind of a video to show
the actual kind of like inner workings
and how it works so I know this is a
pretty quick video but I wanted to kind
of demystify the the recipes package I'm
still learning about it I still think
there is a probably a way to circumvent
the modal imputation for the the the
siblings and spouses abroad but it's
pretty easy to just throw in a median
instead of a mode so I'll see you guys
next week in Taiyuan